Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to. Oh, I don't
know, maybe George from Virginia. George, welcome
to the program. What is on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Awesome. I'm still
traumatized from my last microphone malfunction.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I'm hoping that today we can
sort of, like, clear the air on it.
Speaker 2: Okay. So I was wondering
if you've seen, like, how there's
been an influx of, like, people
attacking the idea of remote work.
Speaker 1: Yes, I have seen that.
Speaker 2: So there was recently an article
published in The New York Times by Steven
Rattner. Hmm. And it's called Is working from
home. Really working. And like this guy tries
to blame SPV collapse and matters failures on
remote workers. And I can't help but feel like
I'm being attacked because I'm a remote worker
and, like, I don't know what their motives are.
But it's a very disappointing.
Speaker 1: So I saw the article
I read a lot in the last couple of months, pro
and against remote work. I actually think that
we don't have nearly enough information yet to say
for sure what are the long term impacts of more.
Set in stone of remote work. We are very early in
you know, we had the pandemic and a ton of stuff
went fully remote. And then right now we're still
in a sort of experimental phase where, you know,
a lot of my friends who are lawyers at corporate
firms, they have to be in Tuesday, Wednesday,
Thursday, but Monday, Friday, they work from home
or other people. It's we have a rotating shift.
So like part of the workforce is Monday, Tuesday,
Wednesday, part is Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday,
part is Wednesday there. You get the idea. I don't
think we actually have enough information yet to
say 100% what are all of the impacts of work from
home. There have been studies about so-called
productivity. And what's often repeated is
productivity is no lower when people are working
from home because even if they're distracted
during the day, because home and work are at the
same place, they end up kind of just like doing
work at more times or whatever the case may be.
For me, it's like it's less about that. My view
is just a little bit different. My view on this is
it can be better or worse for different people
and companies depending on what the priorities
are. Right? Even when you talk about productivity,
I don't know how many people in my audience listen
to Cal Newport's podcast. It is phenomenal.
One of the few podcasts that I actually make
a point to listen to. He has a number of recent
episodes about this sort of thing, and in one of
them he talks about, you know, when we talk about
being productive. For some people, productivity
means squeezing a ton of different things into
a limited amount of time. And so you got to get
organized for that. For others, productivity means
actually I want more free time. So for me, being
productive means squeezing the things I'm expected
to do into fewer hours, to then free me up to do
other things or whatever the case may be. A lot
of this, George, is based on perspective. What
do we mean it's good or bad to work from home? Is
it good or bad productivity wise? Mental health,
socially, environmentally. And I just think a lot
of people are expressing opinions about this right
now and the jury is still sort of out on it.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I agree with that, David.
And I want to say, you know, I am a coder, so I
am an introvert. So it does benefit me to work
from home. And I realize there's other people
where it does benefit. It is like it actually
helps them to work in an office 100% and go
in. But I just want to say like, you know,
you're right, we don't know. And people need
to stop being so confident about, you know,
blaming someone for failures at the top.
Speaker 1: Yeah, There was this clip of
Malcolm Gladwell basically saying working from
home is like ruining everybody's life or whatever.
It's like, yeah, I don't know about that. I'm not.
That seems like a bit much. And I know he's being
controversial and trying to be titillating,
but yeah, I just I think we need a lot more
information and we, not everybody will agree on
what it means to successfully work from home. And
unless you first say, what are we measuring, it's
going to be very hard to get definitive answers.
Speaker 2: Yeah, you're exactly right. So, yeah,
that's it for my call, and I really appreciate it.
Speaker 1: All right. George from Virginia.
Really appreciate hearing from you.